les repères de vampires ne sont
interdits combien de fois faudra
commence pareil si tu connais la loi
mais qu'est ce qu'on vient faire ici je
croyais qu'on cherchait simon on sait où
il est on a juste un peu de
ravitaillement à faire pourquoi ici vous
avez des accords avec l'église
les démons existe à travers le monde
sous des formes diverses et variées les
chasseurs dhombres n'adhère à aucune
religion en particulier en retour toutes
les religions soutiennent notre combat
on aurait pu tout aussi bien aller dans
une synagogue ou un temple shinto les
voilà
au-dessous de l'hôtel de chaque église
tu trouveras ceci en quoi est ce que tu
crois
je crois en moi je sais que mon travail
c'est tous des démons je n'ai pas besoin
de croire entre choisy et l'ange raziel
fois et c'est une jolie histoire où un
dj k o chez lui et devrait sortir plus
souvent je croyais qu'ils écoutent j'ai
passé plus d'un tiers de ma vie à
chasser les démons et pendant tout ce
temps je n'ai jamais vu un ange dieu